hello Internet the way there
this is a slow mo guys video yeah I got
here is a standard procedure 1980s Sony
hide by which spin in my life we use it
so we messed up one of the speaker's
took the front off I'm gonna tip it on
its back and put a lovely selection
that's just rewinding a tape I'm gonna
put a lovely selection of paint dad for
copyright reasons you will not be
hearing the song we danced attune will
replace it with something equally good
[Music]
yeah I've never seen such a nice new
fresh can of paint ruins this is
expensive paints a know which is that
paint like 18 quid a bloody yo where do
you get craft paint or something like
kids pain sorry geez premium how's this
alright let's turn the volume up all the
way to that there's no 11 yeah I get
some predictive focus on the go
predictive focus focus on the actual
paint it's gonna immediately go out
focus some of the folks about here so
that as the droplets right there
apex good word good word it's gonna be a
focus alright Ram it yeah
that's good yeah all right look it have
a look at the playback okay let's go
oh you start to move oh wow that is
awesome well I thought the green is
moving since the water East and the
orange isn't moving yet yeah no it's
awesome so it seemed as though the the
more watery colors they're the ones that
bounce first yeah this time I've tried
to mix them up so they're all kind of
equally watery and they were hope I
think they're all gonna mix in together
once it starts really going for it all
right I've got macro lens on now so
we're really close we're gonna clear
this out and put new coloring and I want
to get those initial blobs of paint just
as they rise up to the top so they look
kind of marble you okay what just above
the speaker just about the speaker it's
perfect watching us now isn't it got it
mastered this
[Music]
really okay that's getting good
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh bright I bet you feel the video is
over well it isn't because right now I'm
gonna do an ad you ready for the app
wait for it here's the app this video
was brought to you by audible bet you
didn't even notice that seamless
obviously you know no audible this top
because you get free book you sign up
you get free audiobook sample and even
if you don't keep the membership you get
to keep the book I recommend it there
are a hundred thousand books Oh what you
want my opinion on which book to get
okay Game of Thrones solid choice bloody
good TV show blend good book and the
audiobook is cool because you get all
the voices read to you in your ear got
me through some pretty severe plane
journeys as well as really long so if
you want one you want a free book for
your book go to audible.com forward
slash slo-mo dad easy alright that's
pretty much it that actually is the end
of the video now there's nothing after
this my advice on what to do next
probably just turn the video off turn it
off just click it out do something else
you can subscribe if you want you can
subscribe for more slower videos if
you've already seen them all then just
wait then the next one will come out in
like a month or something
[Music]
you